pues molestan a todos los enemigos de la
libertad de la democracia a todos los
que quieren esclavizar al ser humano el
mensaje de francia al contrario es un
mensaje de liberación de autonomía del
individuo y de libertad de conciencia y
tenemos un modelo laico en particular en
nuestra en nuestros colegios en nuestros
servicios públicos que no son anti
religiosos no se trata de impedir a los
alumnos por ejemplo
y vivir su religión si creen pero la
idea es dejar cada uno libre de creer o
no creer y de vivir su religión de su
ateísmo en libremente sin tener
presiones o ser matón helado o ser
discriminado por su creencia o falta de
creencia también nos explicó el contexto
de este ataque que ocurrió pocos días
después de presentarse la estrategia del
gobierno para luchar contra el
separatismo y la amistad en comunidades
musulmanas de francia el presidente hace
unos días también anunció algunas
medidas importantes contra lo que llamó
el separatismo grupos que intentan crear
una especie de contra sociedad con
valores que son ajenas ajenos a nuestra
república francesa
y anunció medidas como la obligación de
escolarización de los niños desde los 3
años la limitación de la posibilidad de
escolarizarlos en casa una mejor
capacitación de los imanes los
sacerdotes musulmanes pero también
medidas como la creación instituto de
islam o islam o logía el fomento de la
enseñanza desde el idioma árabe porque
los musulmanes no sé no son el enemigo y
al contrario hay que defenderlos también
contra otro forma de separatismo que son
los que quieren excluir o discriminar a
esa población los enemigos los
terroristas son los radicales islamistas
y queremos controlar mejor en particular
las asociaciones culturales y trabajar
con él
el organismo que agrupa a los musulmanes
de francia para justamente tener un
mejor control sobre la formación de los
sacerdotes de los finales y la
la actividad de las mezquitas y evitar
que caigan en manos de grupos radicales